Avril Lavigne you are
an amalgamation the amalgamation of our
generation's childhood adulthood
angst love breakups all of the above and
everything in between you have been with
me way longer than you know
um you were with me on
all of the times I got my heart broke
your music was in my headphones
um you were an inspiration for a
generation of kids like myself and who
direct War baggy jeans and skated and
you know didn't fit into what
MTV's version of what uh
the girls wanted and when you made
skater boy that was the hope that we you
know hung on to like oh hell yeah we can
we can stay the way we are and there's
someone out there looking for us thank
you guys for coming out
I mean there's no better way to be doing
this today than to have all my friends
here thank you guys so much for coming
out
yeah
and thank you to faldi and MGK for
talking I love you guys
thank you for your words
I mean can you believe it's been 20
years of this
I feel really proud and I feel really
honored to be getting a star today
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
[Music]
okay so I'm 16 years old and I'm on my
first trip to Hollywood and of course I
had to visit the Hollywood Walk of Fame
because it's iconic
so here I am pictured as a 16 year old
in this photograph
[Applause]
y
[Applause]
this is me when I was 16 my first trip
to Hollywood I had to come visit the
Hollywood Walk of Fame this is right
about when I dropped out of high school
[Applause]
can you guys see it over there
[Music]
wearing my skateboarding is not a crime
hoodie
which was my favorite hoodie in high
school
which of course I still have today
so I'm gonna put it on right now
for good luck and Good Vibes
[Applause]
thank you
if it's
[Applause]
so I can remember seeing these legendary
names
and think and I never could have
imagined that mine would be here this is
so crazy I am so grateful this is
probably one of the coolest days of my
life
and so I didn't just get here alone
it took Sacrifice from my family to
allow me to Chase my dreams
my brother Matt Levine thank you for
your undeniable loyalty and dedication
for protecting me and taking care of me
throughout the years
my sister-in-law Amy Levine
my sister Michelle my mom and dad for
pushing me and believing in me
La read for discovering me at 15 years
old
just a
kid from a small town Napanee Ontario
Canada and he believed in me
[Applause]
okay so today we have Lauren Christie is
here
right over here whom I love and adore
and I wrote my first album with Lauren
so I told her how much I was obsessed
with skater boys and skateboarding we
girl talked it up
wrote a song about it the rest is
history
and Lauren I just want to thank you for
being so cool with me for sharing your
talent
for hearing me my vision as like such a
young artist while I was trying to
figure out who I was
and for tapping into that with me
and helping me bring it to life and
writing such meaningful Timeless songs
that people still continue to discover
and connect with today
and then I made my latest album with my
insanely talented fiance mod Sun
I love you
and John Feldman
we love you faldi
Machine Gun Kelly
Travis Barker Black Bear and markopus
[Applause]
[Music]
um
where am I oh yeah
I love you guys you all mean so much to
me I had the most amazing time making
this album genuinely
um
love sucks is the the name of the album
and
for the first time in a while I was
surrounded by people who really
understood me as a person and as an
artist
and I felt like I could really be myself
making this album was a blast
touring it together has been a blast
not only do we make sick music together
and put on Epic concerts together Kells
I'm still waiting stage dive with you
one day
I've made lifelong friends and family
here and for that I am most grateful and
you all have brought so much light into
my life I love you
[Applause]
thank you to my beautiful fan base
my rider dies Sharifah I know you're out
there you've been there from day one
Adam I love you guys thank you for
sticking with me for 20 years and for
everything
and for continuing to support me today
and today
I love making music more than ever I
feel so inspired and I hope that the
next 16 year old from their small town
who comes to Hollywood one day
full of hopes and dreams seize this star
and thinks to themself oh my God my name
could be there one day too because it
can
follow your dreams Live Your Passion
Express Yourself be real work hard keep
your head up believe in yourself
thank you so much for this honor I am so
grateful
to party with you all after
I love you guys this is insane what an
amazing 20 years
and I can't wait for the next 20 [ __ ]